hello everybody my name is Davide I'm a
production engineer at Facebook and I'll
be talking for a bit about what we've
been doing boo systemd
for the past year or so I given versions
of this talk before and hopefully every
year there's something new that's
interesting
I start with a quick recap of the story
so far I'll talk for a bit about what
we're doing for the climate how that
ties into the development workflow we
used for system D I'll quickly go
through a few new features and I'll try
to close with some case that is if
there's time so without further ado as I
said I'm a production engineer I work on
the operating systems team my team is
responsible for maintaining Santos on
the Facebook fleet we have a lot of
machines as you might imagine without
the physical machines all of these
machines run Santos all of these
machines around system D we're on CentOS
7 on the fleet we're starting to prep
1st and 8th but right now everything's
on since seven and by now we've been
doing this for a while
we've been running system B for at least
three years on a wide scale and is he
said to the point where it's pretty much
everywhere is that being quite
interesting seeing internally with how
things moved and how people reacted to
it when we started doing these people
were fairly skittish we had to do a lot
of work explaining people why we were
making the effort to move to system D
what we're doing Center seven and now we
set the point where it's the opposite
we have people reaching out to our team
and water teams fairly frequently with
ideas they have four new features they
want to build that might tie into system
ly or how they might leverage new system
B features for what they are doing and
at the same time we've also had in doing
a lot of development ourselves around
System DNS ecosystem contributing both
to system the proper and to tools around
it and I'll go over some of these so how
do we get system D on the fleet we
deploy system D which chef from our PMS
we don't run the system leaders in
Santos we build it from github because
we want to be able to track what what
apps team is doing so at the end of last
year we weren't two three nine
when 240 was released to 40 was a pretty
big release it took us quite a quite
some time to qualify so we ended up
skipping it for deployment we were
offered two for 2009 two to 41 and then
to 42 which is what's running now as of
today on 98 ish % of the fleet
we started playing with you 43 is it's
nothing why deployment yet but we have
it running in some places
that's probably what I'm gonna start
working on when I get back from this
conference the back part we use is based
on the fedora packaging for is you can
find it there if you're interested in
general this process for speedy well
we'll be doing this for a while we don't
have any major major issues with it
itself the main pain point here is that
the long tail is annoying and the long
tail is pretty small is 2% of machines
but when you have a lot of machines 2%
is still quite a bit and there's too
many reasons for the long tail one
reason is that sometimes you just have
broken machines and broken machines
sometimes don't right chef some time
there are peon database is corrupt
sometimes things happen insisting he
doesn't get updated and for my reason or
another they stick in production and it
takes a while for them to go away I
don't care about those that much because
eventually they'll go away and they're
broken so who cares the thing that's
more annoying is that sometimes when we
do release we have to put in place
exceptions because we will find either
we will find a change in upstream or a
bug or something that affects a specific
customer in a way that they can't quite
update right now and at the same time we
don't want to stop the whole rollout
just for them so we'll pin them to the
previous version and then we'll go on
our sometimes we'll find that something
changed and something our customer was
doing was either wrong or not or doesn't
fit quite well with the model so you end
up tracking these around we have four or
five of these in place right now I think
the oldest goes back to still to 2:39 we
are fairly diligent at cleaning this up
but sometimes you have to deal with that
now as I said the release process works
fairly well but it does take a while
oftentimes from the moment when system
the upstream has released when we deploy
it in production the actual manual work
of prepping the RPMs for testing is a
couple days of work maybe but it can
take quite a while from getting it to
the point where if we feel safe rolling
it on the fleet part of the reason here
is because when when we go from where it
is to another we don't generally do much
testing with what's happening in between
we will follow what's going on upstream
but we do deployments on the three
between major releases so there can be
quite also changes that accumulate and
little late last time that's me no
surprises for people the other thing is
that there's basically two people doing
this which is me and Anita so if one of
us ends up under a bus that's not ideal
what we'd really like to be able to do
is to the development and testing
concurrently most of the time when
people do feature the valley metro
system little do it on master then
they'll end up expert in the patch
internally and testing it on whatever
release we have deployed this isn't too
bad but it is friction we would also
like to be able to do more and faster
integration testing having better ways
to find issues early on and have a fast
50 process both for our developers and
for upstream developers so I started
looking at what we could do there and we
ended up building a little sea ice to
the pipeline for this this is not open
source mostly cuz it ties into internal
stuff it's also not particularly rocket
science we take that with our packaging
I have a horrifying shell script that
replaces the tar ball in there with a
table all made from get master it runs
every day at 10:00 a.m. it builds the
RPM it arounds the test suite as part of
the build if that passes it deploys the
RPM on a small number of machines and we
have a daily running on a small number
of machines we are working right now on
getting this hooked up also with the
container testing infrastructure because
one of the main customers we have
assistant is the container infra so this
way we can find issues early on now this
is something pretty simple and yet these
letters already find a significant
number of issues way before our released
and when we cap to 43 when we got to 42
and later to 43 this was a lot faster we
are this running since March
Elad to filing maybe about 10 yet have
issued between get emissions npr's for
various things we found throughout it
one thing I want to add soon is tell
integration testing of bare metal as
well
I also i've also started looking at
there's a test suite on github that red
that uses for doing the CI based on
CentOS hooked to the upstream repo I
won't start looking this if we can run
those tests internally as well to have
better coverage there so that's not the
deployment side on the development side
as I said we would like to be able to do
faster faster iteration and faster
development and we will also like to be
able to leverage the internal tooling we
have for doing code review for dunya
i right now the way people do code
review for system the changes tends to
be they make a pastebin equivalent of
what their patch is and one of us looks
at it which is not ideal we also already
know how to do this because if you look
at it it is kind of like the kernel
development process so the current plan
is to basically do what the kernel team
does so we are putting together an
internal system via repo that will be
just a read-only mirror what's on github
with the same branches same tags people
will branch off master for future
branches so if they're working on a
thing the branch of master work on there
made their PR hopefully they'll build a
thing cut from it and test it before
they make a PR but you know this way at
least I think that signal on what's
going on when we make releases will
branch releases of released appear
release tags cherry-pick for the future
branches that the release this has also
the benefit that we can get rid of the
heavy pile of patches we use right now
with the RPM packaging and we'll just
have a simple script to grab hatches
from from the get tree this is exactly
what the kernel team does we think it
might work and make life easier for us
and hopefully lead to having better
better and faster feedback outside as
well but we'll see
and I be actually be interested to hear
if other folks here do internal
development for system D what the well
process you use or if you build tooling
around this now let's go over quickly a
few new features that landed recently
I'm not going to spend too much time on
this because there's been a lot of other
talks from Facebook people on things and
I'd rather have them talk about what
they work on one thing that hasn't come
up yet that is pretty cool and ended up
in 243 uses a condition exact condition
is something that Anita developed it's
kind of a hybrid between condition and
exact start free where internal commands
before the unit is started actually
before the pre scripts run and depending
on the exit code of the command it can
pass so it will keep running the unit it
can fail mark the unit has failed or you
can skip execution kind of when a
condition fails now why would you want
to do this well I can only why we want
to do this the reason we want to do this
is that we want to gently nudge people
to do continuous deployment of their
tools so we want to have a binary a tool
that checks the binary and if the binary
is 200
just refuse to start the service and
then do a bunch of other things but
that's that's one of the main reasons
and this is a fairly these are fairly
simple and straightforward way to do it
there's a possible improvement where we
could maybe have a personal specifier so
we don't have to copy the name of the
binary there but that's that's just
sugar this is actually a pretty good
example of I think feature development
that goes well because we came up with
the idea of maybe we should do something
like this before Christmas
internally we discussed it we played
with a few ideas we were in Brno in
February for that conf we met with the
system developers we discussed this with
them we brainstormed on possible designs
and we ended up with oh yeah do we like
this seems to be simple enough and it
could work and then it was coded in the
months afterwards and it landed in 243 I
think this is pretty much the ideal way
you want development to go on the
resource management found the boot
there's already been several talks
tissue and then still cover resource
control in general the Elenita talked
about md Yanis is gonna talk later today
about some PI 2 things I wanna raise
theirs disabled controllers that landed
for transient units as well disabled
controllers is quite handy because it
allows you to turn off specific
controllers without having to rely on
kernel command line flags so without
having to reboot the box the other
single-ended is a number of oom oom
specific control for the kernel another
user space whom around sigil - notably
un policy so you can apply room settings
to specific see herbs something else
we've been working on for widest PI
system D algorithm talked on this
yesterday so presently is available
there is a thin size on wrapper on top
of SD bus if perhaps the SD buzz API
with the idea of making it easier to
interact with system D but it also
allows you to poke at the bus in general
right now this supports pretty much all
the Divas properties exposed by system D
it's been working quite well we've been
very happy with it and we started
building quite a lot of tooling around
it internally I would like to see to see
this more used in general because at
least in my experience is one of the
most stable ways to interact to the bus
from Python once in the land Eve
recently is also socket support so you
can do
fairly neat or terrifying things
depending on your point of view where
when you that's just an example you can
import to try it but what that does
under the hood is that it makes a
friends in stock it makes the transient
service then Forks off and a little
Python web server and it ends up being
managed as a proper service with a
proper socket which is nice I mentioned
before we use chef for config management
we have a cookbook called fu system D
for managing system leads and github
it's been there for a while with a
respite a bit of work on these in the
last half-hour so mostly internals one
thing that's interesting is when you've
right on disk system units you had
generally and ability I using templates
do using templates for managing over
eyes is what we're doing before it's
really annoying because you end up
writing the same boilerplate code which
is make the directory make the template
and delete the directory clean up the
template reload system these obnoxious
so I've got a little customer resource
in chef that lets you drop an override
and internally figures out where should
it go
it cleans it up when it needs to be
cleaned up it did reload system v when
needs to be reloaded this is pretty
useful and it's straightforward enough
and the syntax is about the same as the
upstream system the unit resource in
chef then one more thing that Chris town
has been working on lately is a linter
for system units when people use system
D they find about a lot of features a
system he has and they start using them
some of these features are great some of
these features would really rather than
not use them like one example is people
using kill mode equal process and not
really understanding what it does are
people using interesting settings for
namespacing without really understanding
them so all of these are things that are
well-suited for limiting there's already
a bare-bones it's not real interest more
of a consistency checker built into
system D dash analyze this is meant more
of a general-purpose
LinkedIn tool where you can define a
policy for the things you care about and
then it can surface them we have this
running internally it exists and it
works we would like to open source it by
the end of the year it's a standalone
tool so there's not in facebook
specific in it hopefully people will
find it useful and maybe it will help
other companies and folks prevent issues
there okay I have a couple of horror
stories on the same theme of implicit
dependences so on this one we had a
bunch of machines where after we rolled
out a new loop system diversion I do
remember he was 241 242 we started
seeing that NTP was not starting on but
after considerable digging we discover
that the NTP service in in Santos uses
private temp which is fine except
private temp internally takes a
dependency implicit definition time that
mount which I did not know and only
found out after digging through this
this would be great except on these
machines for because of the way they
were set up people didn't really notice
that the way they were set up was that
they would boot 10 mount would start and
do you think but then we would mask time
the mount in chef so you will end up
with this unit that would be both active
and masks which is probably not
something that's supposed to work and in
fact while this works in 239 in the
sense that by worse I mean it doesn't
complain from on later versions system
you will heart fail and refuse to start
a unit that happens to have a dependency
on a thing that is was active and masked
so yeah this was now great this was
actually one of the reasons the things I
mentioned before we had to pin pin this
fleet to 239 for a while while we fear
this out I took us probably a week
working on it on and off because it
wasn't really a showstopper we we could
keep it running just fine when it was
back on 239 so yeah implicit
dependencies are kind of annoying
we had another case like that where we
had a we had some hosts where some tired
soldiers were on their own boot after
digging we found that the temp files not
was not being created because this in
the temple said that never ran and since
the attempt has set up the pencil look
at the fast which depends on swath
except one of my colleagues was working
on this cookbook called FP swap to do
encrypted swap and a bunch of other
things and he added a whole bunch of
masks the unit has the panel swapped of
target
which makes the whole thing fail so the
entire figure you guys prone it doesn't
exist anymore
and you end up we know tempers the way
we debug this by the way both of these
problems but this one specifically was
uses in the analysis in the analysis to
really hand the commands plot and dot
one will give you a butcher style plot
of the boot the other will give you the
octopus style dependency graph the
dependency graph is completely useless
in our case because it ends up being
this gigantic thing but you can tell it
to only show you a subset of it
which is very helpful you can also
enable debug logging impede one either
by killing it with a special signal or
by passing a command line flag this is
actually how we found this out because
we ended up seeing the debug message
that said these three is getting prone
because this thing doesn't exist anymore
and that's all I have questions
[Applause]
hi you mentioned that you are starting
to think of debugging system D like
debugging the kernel developing
developing eternal but also I guess
developing involves debugging can you
can you take a labyrinth at analogy
between kernel level stuff and
government are you bisecting things are
you the whole the whole range of with me
so I meant that primarily in terms of
development workflow more than then
specifically under the bagging side in
terms of development we have a very well
honed process where we have an internal
kernel tree we use the exactly that the
feature branch branches in the release
branches model we have automated testing
for the kernel we have CI we have
automated deployments we have very good
way to understanding either vsti or the
a/b testing whether a specific change is
gonna impact things and how it's gonna
impact them and we would like to bring
that to system D as well and eventually
to other system software we work on for
debugging specific issues I I mean it
ends up becoming it's very different
actually I think I'm developing the
kernel in some senses and it tends to be
very hit-or-miss what I personally do is
play with the deploy with the debug
logging play with tools available on Vox
surprisingly often times tracing pit 1
and something very useful for
understanding what's going on
we had a couple of cases when it up with
p1 deadlocked or in bad stage I talked
about them last year actually and in
those cases tracing was how we found out
what the hell was going on there
we had interesting and tricky
interactions between kernel a user space
sometimes especially when there's API
mismatches or things that changed but
that doesn't I would say that doesn't
really happen that often nowadays we got
pretty good at that
mmm
I would I would assume that that
Facebook you are logging a lot of a lot
of stuff to use journal d or do you have
a different loggers login system are
your lovely in remotely or locally we
were in journal de oh and every machine
in the fleet we are under and by default
we run journal II with a 10 megabyte
volatile journal and then we ran our C's
log and all the machines and our syslog
ships the logs off somewhere I I don't
know what happens after was actually
there there is a lot collection
infrastructure - by the security team
for that the reason we do this is
because people really like being able to
grab phallic messages and stuff like
that and there's some amount of tooling
that also does a donation sometimes
based on that we've been trying to move
people towards that you're on a locus
usually what happens is that I give up
training internally on this and people
relate to each other it's nice and they
would really like to use it and I find
out all that you're not CTL commands
they could use and they asked me if they
can apply it is is kind of difficult to
have posted shown on our syslog running
concurrently because you had the double
writing and causing a lot of extra IO
and we have applications that can be
extremely chatty in terms of logging so
if you end up writing 3 gigabytes a
second of logs that's that's not great
one thing that will help we we've been
looking at ways right now the journal is
a bit all or nothing endeavor because
either is entirely volatile or is
entirely on this we've been looking at
ways that we could have a per-unit
setting here and devil I'll transition
things over because in other cases it
will be one application team that would
really like to use this journal but
maybe everybody else not quite yet
I think this is one of the scenes that I
might play with when we start rolling
out the next Santos release and see if
we can couple with that rollout maybe
not Jim people to use this more
have you looked into like using our
syslog-ng
because it has modules to slurp up the
journal d and as well as syslog entries
and other things together such as those
who want wrapping our syslog they can
and those who use journal they can and
you're writing once and storing ones
well you can do that but but you still
you eat you still end up writing twice
though don't you sure but then while
you're on journal CTL you only get the
the small buffer you have because yet
that does that's kind of the problem
there yeah we we actually ever sees look
set up that way right now I think it
uses the the module to get the IIM K
journal or something yeah yeah that's
kind of the problem because if you if
you only have a small volatile buffer
then if you actually want to use on a
CDL or if you do systems justice on
something you see no more logs and and
that's that's a bit annoying
regarding the linter heat tool wondering
since you mention it's more than just
linting may be analyzing - why not
integrated into systemd analyze and
might then if not you know why not and
then also then with the versions of
system D changing and you know file
being different how do you manage that
so some of the things that we wanted to
do in the link there actually ended up
in analyze one thing specifically was
parsing time specs and validating the
time specs like we do on calendar or
something were correct that ended up
being implemented as a feature in allies
itself I think implementing the whole
interest part of analyze is something
that would probably be possible I think
he would maybe be kind of out of scope
for analyze itself especially because we
wanted specifically these two e
pluggable in terms of policy and have
maybe the ability to have more complex
policies I don't know how well that will
feed their crease is actually there and
you can answer that more usefully than I
can most likely
I think you so another reason is because
if you look inside the system D source
like one of the things we have is kind
of we have a lot of little bits of unit
state we have a lot of little bits of
like go low for this thing in storage
somewhere you don't really have a way to
kind of homologate that back to here is
how the unit of all looks or here is how
you know you can get something in
systemctl show but it's hard to map that
back to like here is how we got to that
outcome and that's often the thing we
need to know is like how do we get here
so it currently it's hard to just make
it part of systemctl analyst because i
mean you would you can do it but you
would again have to kind of reinvent a
unit passer and do all kinds of other
stuff and I think it doesn't make a
whole lot of sense
Thank You Danielle's free talk oh you
got a quick 500 brake sorry